thanks
okay so uh
thanks for the organizers for doing this
like misha and james and other people
it's actually a lot of fun
so i'm sean kakere i'm at microsoft
research new england
uh the question i'll be looking at today
is
how do we learn latent variable models
or models with hidden factors and these
are models which are pretty useful in a
variety of
settings because we like to find
reasonable representations of the world
and often if we can get better
representations of the of the world
they will help us in technological
applications so you know a couple years
ago vicos gave this very nice talk on
uh speech you know deep learning
alternatives to these learning methods
in uh in the audio domain and you know
in inside this pipeline a lot of the
major advances really came from
different acoustic representations and
you know we're trying to tease these
things apart but there is this sort of
widespread belief if we can really get
better representations of the world
we'll get performance bumps on tasks
we're interested in and in this talk
we're going to look at
uh
two natural models
for
the ways in which we represent the world
one is this mixture of gaussian's
problem
where we see points in space
look something like this and i say tell
me the means
okay so there's some underlying data
generation model and we want to figure
out the means and a harder question for
this
model is suppose your data look like
this
now this is a neat question because in
this case you kind of clearly see these
guys have different means
this case is pretty neat because they're
right on top of each other you think of
this as the mean zero mixture of
gaussian case
okay and this is a much more challenging
question to learn because in a sense
you're mixing up psd matrices but we'll
look at this question as well
okay so there's an abstraction which is
how do we learn gaussian mixtures
there's another problem of how we learn
topics and documents so these are
models where we have a set of documents
and we think each document document has
one or more topics inside it okay and we
see
are there collections of documents or
collection of points
and how do we learn these
and in particular we'd like estimators
where
we get some statistical guarantees along
with computational guarantees
so
here the basic question is what are the
the limits of what we can learn both
computational and statistical
and
for these gaussian mixtures there's a
very nice paper by anker and greg really
showing that for reasonably well
separated gaussians in 1d you're going
to need exponential number of samples in
in k where k is the number of gaussians
and it's an information theoretic lower
bound
okay so at some level we can't really
expect to learn these things all the
time
uh even when they're reasonably well
separated i mean
they still are close together but it was
an information theoretic lower bound in
1d
there's been various results
about hardness for a maximum likelihood
estimation in these models which is
slightly different because that's not an
information theoretic hardness result
so
the question is going to be under
what assumptions and models uh
you know can we learn and how general
can we make these things
so you know this work is going to review
a line of work that
we've been involved in which basically
is arguing that
uh
under many natural settings some of
these hardness results
uh don't apply and we actually learn
these models like the spherical mixture
of gaussian's case and subtopic model
modeling cases
and basically do this with simple linear
algebra approaches basically
generalizations of svd and these aren't
convex optimization problems yet we can
still do them
okay but there's a pretty you know
at least recently
a bunch of my research has been
switching gears but
but one question that's been on the back
of my mind is this learning mixture of
general gaussians because there's sort
of one trick we used in the line of work
here
and
we're really wondering if this was
limiting
and are there really
barriers when we start looking at more
general cases and i think this is really
the hard case for the mixture of
gaussians take a mixture of zero mean
gaussians
they're right on top of each other and
you're effectively getting
kind of a mixture of psd matrices
and recently we can basically we've
shown we can actually solve this and
i'll highlight some of the results there
as well
but it's an interesting tensor because
the tensor is arising
not in a pure sense it's arising from
a mixture of psd matrices so i i'll
briefly discuss that and highlight this
new result but it's kind of a
different set of ideas
okay
so
yes in terms of related work there's
really
quite a lot of related work i can't go
through all the details but in the
theoretical computer science community
there's been a lot of very nice work
when we have separation assumptions how
we can learn these things and then we
don't have separation assumptions uh
there's some nice work starting with uh
adam klein co-authors and misha velken
and co-authors of how we can learn
mixtures of gaussians uh
in
in an information theoretic sense and
topic models there's also been a nice
line of work and in a sense i would say
this line of work really traces back
more on the cystic side from the
statistician joseph chang
who originally understood
identifiability of phylogeny trees and
that led to some nice work by alhanon
and
and uh sebastian roach on learning uh
phylogeny trees which eventually
uh influenced our ideas and then we
realized the connections between many
different communities
so let's
and definitely ask questions so let's
just uh
go through
the model slowly and
and uh tackle the problem
okay so let's set things up
uh
it's a mixture of gaussian's problem
all right think of having k means mu and
mu k
and how are we going to generate our
data first we're going to sample a
cluster i with probability w i
then for now let's assume we have
spherical noise
uh
we're going to get a data point x which
is a mean
plus some noise where the noise is
perturbed by
some spherical gaussian noise
and our data set is going to be just
a bunch of points in some space
okay so we're clear with that
and the topic modeling case is
the simple the single topic modeling
case and we're going to work in the
statistical settings so we've got take k
topics think of mu1 and uk as
multinomial distributions
okay and we're going to sample topic i
with probability wi and then the way we
get a document is we take our
multinomial distribution and get m draws
of words from this particular
multinomial distribution
okay so then our document which is going
to be x1 to xm is going to be m draws
so these are each uh
some atoms in a
set
sample it independently from ui
and we get multiple documents which are
collections of words and we are ignoring
the order so is the setting clear okay
so
and the game is how do you estimate
things you're going to either see points
or you're either going to see
documents and your goal is to tell me
the muse w's and the spherical
covariances
and for this
zero mean case just to set it up
just think about this in parallel
there are the parameters a w i and a set
of psd matrices sigma i
and we're going to sample i from with
probability w i
and we're going to see x from a normal
which is mean 0 and covariance sigma i
so this is a
sort of significantly more challenging
problem
okay
so we're good with notation here
and
what's the game well we're just going to
look at the method moments
we'll start laying out these moments and
try to see if we can invert them this is
an old idea from pearson look at the
structure in our problem trying to find
the parameters consistent with this
problem and this is going to make some
nice connections to tensors and linear
algebra because
this is really this classic inverse
moments problem
but what's interesting is for this um
mixture of zero means gaussians it'll
actually give rise to
a rather different
moment structure than we've seen before
because it's coming from psd matrices
and
this
this question is kind of interesting for
the topic model case because you know
let's look at the moments with a mixture
of gaussians these are just the mean
like a covariance matrix and then
three-way correlations but for the topic
model case the moments are interesting
because what's the first moment it's
just the average distribution over the
words in the language what's the second
moment you can think about this as being
specified as the distribution over
pairs of words in a document so it's a
bigram distribution what's the third
moment it's just the distribution
under which three words tend to appear
together
right and this inverse moments problem
is interesting because
uh suppose every document had one word
in it and you had an infinite collection
all you could get is the average
distribution of words and it's clearly
not identifiable it's not even a
uh statistical
sample size issue here it's just not
identifiable if every document has one
word in it
so if we have you know if we're going to
solve this problem at the very least
we're going to have to be able to
understand
how many words in a document do we need
to have before it's identifiable so are
two words in a document enough to get
identifiability and so on
and
that's why these identifiability proofs
while sometimes they're tricky if we can
make them if we can think about this
issue and maybe make it algorithmic it
gives us
uh some way to address these problems
so this is the game we're just going to
start looking at some moments and try to
invert them
yep
when you have p uh probability of x one
x two i i assume you're uh this is a
co-occurrence problem it's a
co-occurrence probability of two words
in a document right so if i have a
particular document where x1 actually
appeared twice and x2 once that's still
counted as one characteristic
now think of it as just a
um
okay so
think of this as just a bag of words uh
model so so then you would be just
estimating
uh
you know if they were ordered then this
is an issue at all so simple so for
simplicity think of the first word
second or third word and you can
estimate that and then just make it so
you know make it symmetric
so yeah
i guess the question is it's not just
coconuts right it's frequencies aren't
you counting frequencies
i say that occurrences mean something
different from one occurred right
so one way to estimate to this quantity
so let's just say every document had two
words in it
just for just for simplicity the way
you'd get an empirical average of this
is just the expected value of the
indicator function of those two words
appearing what if it has more words are
you going to count the numbers i mean
so so think of just um
i
you know just think of getting any
reasonable unbiased estimate of this
quantity and then you would count the
numbers uh appropriately so think of
just uh
uh
you know one way to do this just sample
from the document compute the empirical
expectations uh but there's an easy way
you all get okay you definitely are
going to utilize more words per document
but for now just think of this as you're
getting better unbiased estimates of
this quantity
so take the frequency right you'll take
the frequencies and adjust them
appropriately together yeah so think of
it just like
all i'm asking is
frequencies matter or just occurrence or
not frequencies matter
that's okay that's right and in fact uh
for now um think of these as separate
questions for now suppose i just give
you exact moments because uh once we
think of approximate approximate moments
we're just it was actually just how this
sampling issue just how do we estimate
these and and then if we have more words
per document we're going to get better
estimates of these where the frequencies
matter but for now let's just suppose we
have exact moments but certainly in
practice we would absolutely use
the fact that we have more words in a
document
so
let's just use vector notation it's it's
nice uh so mixture of gaussians x is
going to be a vector in d dimensions
suppose we have k gaussians so a nice
thing with conditional expectation is
the expected value x given its from
cluster i is just the mean
good for that and the nice thing about
the topic modeling case we're just going
to treat
uh words
as
vectors with this hot encoding so the
first word we'll treat as a vector of
zero with one on and zero so this means
the second word no vocabulary occurred
right and this is convenient because we
can say the probability of a word given
topic i is just the expected value of x1
given the topic i which is mu i we just
think of these topics as probability
vectors in space
so we get just with this notation so
this is convenient because we can write
out moments and use the new algebra
now let's just start look looking at
some moments and see if we can invert
these things
so the first one is simple right so
what's the first moment for the
makeshift guardians problem it's just
the average of the miui's
okay what's the first moment for the
topic model in problem it's actually
just the uh also the average of the
mewis this location
good of that
okay
let's just compare this to this problem
for a moment now
so so first are we good with these
moments right these are pretty
straightforward okay so let's look at
this
problem for the the mixture of zero mean
gaussians here the first moment is zero
because everything's your amine
so it's sort of natural to compare to
the second moment here so what's the
expected value of x x transpose here
it's actually
just the average of
the psd matrices we see
the mean is zero but the second moment
for this mixture of covariance matrices
is just the average
covariance matrix
okay
because in a sense
this mixture of zero means gaussians is
like
getting
uh
you know it's sort of like xx transpose
is the natural quantity to look at
because in expectation those are the
sigma eyes condition on which gusting
it's from
i mean this is a true statement
and either way we cut it if i give you
these quantities exactly you can invert
them
if i tell you
here's a mean here's a mean for the
topic model in case so here's the
covariance matrix and i say tell me the
parameters of the model you can't invert
it
so how are you doing the weights for the
topic modeling is there like frequencies
being used at all so yeah so w is
let's just say one
uh each document has one topic let's do
the simplest case and wi specifies the
probability of a document having topic i
right so the way you draw a doc
the way you generate a document is first
pick a topic pick topic i would probably
wi and generate the words according to
the corresponding multinomial
distribution
good
so now things
uh start getting a little more
interesting so let's look at the second
moment
for the second moment
the mixture of gaussian's
case where
in the spherical case let's just assume
for the spherical case
all of the variances are the same
so then you're going to get
when we look at the second moment we get
mean plus noise mean plus noise so we
get one term
which is like how the means relate to
each other plus this additive term which
is due to the noise sigma squared times
the identity
right
and the topic model case
we look at the joint distribution of two
words
because the words are generated
independently it just looks like the sum
of w i mu i and ui transpose
okay
and we good with this and now the game
is like suppose i just gave you this
exact way and i said tell me can you
tell me the muse and sigma for this case
or can you tell and the w's and can you
tell me the w is the muse here you
should think of this as a math problem
now i give you these moments can you
invert them
it turns out it's still not identifiable
and it's not identifiable in
uh even the topic myelin case if you
impose
the probabilistic constraints it's
really not identifiable and it's sort of
not identifiable on every problem uh so
i think even joseph chang in his paper
for follow-up she's given example that
really is degenerate so two words per
document aren't enough
uh so it's still not identifiable but
parameter cutting suggests we're getting
closer actually let's look at this
question for the
the case of
mixtures of zero mean gaussians because
now let's look at the fourth moment so
what is the fourth moment of a gaussian
with zero mean
all right so we're going to look at
the expected value
of the fourth moment
and look let's look at the coordinates i
j k l
okay for a and let's do this for a
single gaussian
so this is a gaussian with
mean zero variant sigma
well there's these counting theorems uh
that tell you how to specify this but
you know what you know i'll just write
it out
basically i'm just
uh
permuting these indices so
uh you get the matchings correct because
you know in 1d what is the the fourth
moment of gaussian it's three times
the variance squared
okay
and the generalization for this for the
multivariate case is this object
and basically you're looking at all
perfect matchings of your four
all indices so this is just you know
just the structure of these moments but
this is just for one gaussian
okay
and
let me just call this condition on sigma
and what you're gonna get for the for
the fourth moment in the zero main case
is a mixture of these objects so call
this
m4
of o of a particular gaussian
that's expected value
of what power of x condition on sigma i
and what you're going to observe
is
the average
fourth moment over the gaussians and
suppose i give you this object exactly
so this is a tensor that's been
constructed of psd matrices
and i'm going to ask you to tell me
these psd matrices turns out it's not
identifiable here but it's a
much more delicate question of how you
recover this object
so so we'll keep going so but we see you
know there's interesting structure in
these problems this one is the simplest
so what's the rank of this object
okay
right whereas this thing is full rank
and then of course for the mixture of
zero mean gaussians when we look at the
fourth moment this is a confusing object
but it's neat and these sort of uh
these counting theorems kind of come up
often in cs cs3
this is a bit tricky right because you
have the dimension and the number of
components interplay right in low
dimension for example if they don't have
enough parameters i haven't discussed
identifiability at all this is just
uh this is a tensor of size d to the
four
and
i'm just giving it to you exactly
whether you can recover or not can
recover it you can't recover it at all
even in high dimensions with the fourth
movement
even the fourth moment we yeah even with
the the fourth moment we have examples
with two gaussians that this isn't
enough to recover the
uh
the sigma yep uh make sure it dashed in
single topics is the is the root of the
issue here that you know rotations of
rank when decompositions are still
ranking compositions you can think about
that yeah like there's nothing more
going on than that yeah
i mean the topic modeling case is a
little more subtle because you have this
constraint that these have to be in the
positive orthant and some to one
uh which is why
maybe this is has teeth but it doesn't
it is the bottom line
the parameter counting is just you're
getting close but in a sense this is
exactly the right intuition because the
amount you're off by
uh sort of then you know the thing you
need to specify is basically the number
of parameters for a rotation
okay
this is that is exactly the right
intuition which we're trying to
uh like because suppose the the noise
was zero and i just gave you this object
and i said tell me the muse you can't do
it
and it's exactly for the reasons you
mentioned let's go ahead and proceed in
for now let's just look at the single
topic model because that's the simplest
case to look at
and once we figure that out we can come
back to the other ones
okay so
yeah so it's pretty clear just what the
the structure of the three-way
correlations of a single topic model are
going to look like
right it's just going to be
as if
the three words were generated from the
same topic summing over wi
so we're good with this
so now we've just raised this as and
let's just forget about
the
both mixture of gaussian
problems for a moment but we can see
you know if we look at the sixth moment
of a gaussian it's going to be more
complicated ways to swap indices
and and we'll come back to that moment
we'll just look at this case because it
highlights
the problem here and let's just think of
this as a math problem i'm going to give
you a matrix i tell you it has this
structure i'm going to give you a tensor
so this is a d cubed object where each
entry specifies the three way
the probabilities of three words
co-occurring just think of this as a
math problem i give you these objects
and i ask you can you tell me the mu
eyes
if you can
then it's identifiable
if they're unique up to permutations
and basically we've seen this problem uh
come up many times uh in this workshop
because this is just a tensor
decomposition problem
okay and
this is nice we've really just reduced
this problem
to
a tensor decomposition problem and just
to show you this is easy to solve
suppose
uh we made
the second moment the identity matrix we
did a linear transformation
uh to make it look
so i'm going to give you what does that
do that basically in this new coordinate
system that basically makes these muse
orthogonal to each other
so we can
we can reduce the problem now to
give you a matrix which is the identity
and i give you a tensor
uh where it has this decomposition and i
tell you the mu is orthogonal
so now it's just an orthogonal tensor
decomposition
and you know if i didn't have this mu
here what is this decomposition
that's the svd
so this is really just the standard
generalization of an svd and
of course the way you solve it now is
well there are many ways to solve it but
you could just say find me the
eigenvectors of the tensor and by
eigenvectors of a tensor i mean
you know
when we hit a matrix
with two vectors we just mean we sum out
the indices when we hit a tensor a three
tensor with three vectors we just sum
out the indices in the usual way we can
define an eigenvector
uh similar to how we define it for a
matrix of a matrix we define eigenvector
as we take our matrix hit it with a
vector and it's stable under the vector
for tensor we can think about hitting
the matrix with a vector twice let's
look for stable points and if you think
about
what that means here
you know let's hit this tensor with a
matrix sorry hit this tensor with a
vector twice we get this expression
right because
when we hit it with the v twice we're
really just hitting the mu i's and we're
trying to find a solution for this
equation
and since the mu's are orthogonal
what v via satisfy this
the uis
and that's basically the solution
and that's sort of why this and that's
really the identifiability proof as well
so what did we need for this to work out
was sort of your point we need
the
dimension of our vectors
to be
sort of the number of mu eyes that needs
to be
smaller than the dimension we're in
because we need this whitening step to
work out which means we need these
vectors to be linearly independent
and as long as we have that the
whitening will work out and this thing
has a unique solution
any decomposition it's not too hard to
show uniqueness
so now so now it's just a protubation
argument and how sharp can we make
these bounds but this basically gives us
the idea for the single topic model
and
basically the algorithm now is estimate
your empirical moments find the tensors
and
that's how you solve the problem but the
first theorem is just the exact case as
long as these topics are linearly
independent
then
we have the identifiability that these
eigenvectors
are the topics and they say robust just
because there's some kind of saddle
point ignore the uh there's there's
basically a few unstable eigenvectors
uh yep
all right so just make sure i'm getting
the parameters right uh does this say
that for the top for topic modeling um
that i need the length of my document to
be
the number of documents in my corpus to
get the dimensions to match yeah so you
need the uh this says the length of your
document needs to be three
because with three words per document
you can estimate the trigram
probabilities
so what am i using here i'm saying i
uh get so the ambient dimension
right so the ambient dimension is we've
got k topics okay okay and these topic
probability vectors are an r to the d
because you've got d words
okay and we need k to be less than or
equal to d for this to work out
okay so number of documents have to be
less the number of unique words in the
language yes uh and
uh but we only need three words per
document
and that's uh and and basically it has
to be generic so if they're linearly
independent this will break but sort of
under any reasonable smooth analysis
model this is fine
and now in terms of sample complexity
well it's just how do we
how do we do this well you just get
empirical estimates and you run this
algorithm it's a little delicate because
now you're decomposing a perturbed
tensor so you need to put a basin
analysis
and there is a little technical machine
machinery here because unlike in svd
there are these nice magic perturbation
theorems which is take your matrix
compute an svd
and we can relate the svd of a perturbed
matrix to the svd of a true matrix these
like davis cajon theorems and
whedon's theorem for tensors there's no
such analog because
you can't just do
a tensor decomposition of a perturbed
tensor
you need an algorithm to do it
but
basically what we can show is
with a small number of restarts just
running the power method
will converge to
some eigenvector that's close to a true
one
so basically in this paper we get an
analog of
uh essentially these matrix perturbation
theorems for tensors
and i think without further assumptions
it's the sharpest we really know how to
do
at least for the under complete setting
uh and what's interesting is for these
tensor cases you don't really need eigen
gaps because every tensor is stable on
the on their own we don't need any
you know the eigenvalues could be the
same and you're still going to recover
them because of this third power there
and so that means basically the
accuracies
in our perturbation theorem depends on
some kind of tensor or epsilon divided
by the eigenvalue of the tensor so
there's no eigengap
which is nice because
that's what allows
um
yeah it would be problematic if
we couldn't figure out these
eigenvectors when the eigenvalues were
the same that's not an issue here
all we really need is the eigenvalues to
be bounded away from zero and that's
what governs the diff the statistical
difficulty of this problem
so we're good with basic
at this point right at least for
polynomial types of guarantees we just
figure out the sample size we need to
get a certain act
accuracy on this triplet counts
such as how many documents do we need
and then we plug it into this
prohibition result and this perturbation
result is really has nothing to do with
this particular problem it's just for
any cancer which orthogonal
decomposition exists this gives you
uh sort of a nice prohibition
vibration bond along with an argument
too and i think it's the sharpest
uh
without stronger assumptions i don't
know how to make this
uh
make this
bond sharper
okay so now let's go back to so we're
good with this this is just the simplest
case
but this really highlights the game here
right at least
can we
take our latent variable model and try
to massage it into a problem we know how
to solve and for the most part there are
few classes of
higher moment decompositions we know how
to solve
are you good with this
what about the spherical mixture of
gaussian case and actually this harder
mixture of gaussian case
so we can back up a bit
and see how we can solve those
so what went wrong in the spherical
mixture of gaussian case well we have
this additive term here
right and that's just for the second
moment
but what is this sigma squared
can we figure it out if i just give you
this matrix can you tell me what sigma
squared is
suppose is k less than d any guesses
and intuitively it's basically
you know as long as k is less than d you
kind of have to have variance sigma at
least variance sigma squared in all
directions
so just find the direction with minimal
variance
and that's basically the direction you
know not in the subspace bound by the
means and that's sigma squared and
mathematically it's just the smallest
eigenvalue
okay so you know sigma squared so you
can subtract it off
now the point is for the third moment
for this problem you're just going to
get some extra terms that have to do
with sigma squared and lower order
moments
so you can just write out the structure
of the third moments subtract some stuff
off and reduce it to the same problem we
can solve
it's delicate if the variances weren't
all
the same sphere
coming from the same sigma because then
this trick doesn't work but and we can
solve that but basically this is the
right idea that you can get sigma
squared as the minimal eigenvalue
and you look at the third moment and you
manip and you can manipulate it
so here's the reduction for
the mixture of spherical gaussians when
when the spherical variances are all the
same grab sigma squared is the minimum
eigenvalue subtracted out the second
moment
and for the third moment
what's happening you really just
you know what's the third moment of a
single gaussian a single scalar gaussian
the third moment is really mu plus three
sigma squared times mu
that's the mu cubed
so the scalar gaussian this is the the
third moment
and basically just we just want to get
rid of this stuff
and it turns out if you just you know
these eis are the standard basis but
think of this as just like 3 mu sigma
squared
so you subtract that out and you make
basically a tensor is exactly of the
same form
so again this is a reduction that we try
to
take the problem massage it to a problem
we can solve and it turns out with some
algebraic tricks you can do this and you
can do this even if the sigmas are
different
as long as they're spherical
this is really the idea and then you can
just plug in the sample complexity
balance
so are we good with that
so now comes for the really
hard question which is
all of the tricks we knew how to solve
up to now
were basically reductions to
this orthogonal tensor decomposition
but this zero mean case is really screwy
because
our tensors don't
really look like this they're
kind of getting constructed from
psd matrices with indices screwed up
right so so this theorem is
what the fourth moment of a single
gaussian looks like so this theorem i
think it's called the isolus
theorem it basically says
um
that suppose x
is a
multivariate gaussian and we look at
the two amps the moment of this gaussian
and so we look at indices i 1 to i
2 m all the odd moments are 0.
you can write the moment
the even moments of a single gaussian as
basically a sum over perfect matchings
of the
the
the indices
times the product
over the pairs of the indices
of u and v basically a generalization of
this object so if i go to the sixth
moment i'm gonna have three objects like
this where i'm commuting the indices up
and this is a neat question because
somehow a cancer is being made of
mixtures of psd matrices and now let's
just say i give you this object
can you reverse engineer
these
covariance matrices
and this is a problem i was bugging a
lot of people about for the last few
years
trying to say how do you
recover psd matrices
that are mixed up in this way and
you know we thought a fair bit about
this and we actually were trying to use
some work by pablo so you have this
paper with ben wrecked and fazo on
kind of trace norm minimization
because so the main observation is if
you have
suppose we just look at the fourth
moment
what we'd really like to do is make a
tensor
let's call this x4
where
the columns are these psd matrices
if i didn't have these two terms this
would be great because i just viewed
this tensor as a matrix and i just want
to say my columns are these matrices
this is what i would really like to do
just say that you know basically i just
want to say i can make a problem instead
of mu eyes i have sigma eyes here where
the sigma i's are just you know the
matrix as a vector but the problem is
you can't get that because they're mixed
up
but the key observation is the way that
they're mixed up is a linear
transformation
because
what we have is this
we'd like an object where
that it looks like this
where you have sigma across sigma where
you can think of each sigma as a
as a
vector
and these objects are linear related in
fact we know the coefficients in which
they're linear related because they're
exactly coming from these perfect
matching theorems
uh but it turns out the conditions were
neat at least from these are it's sort
of coherent in the worst possible way
that at least inverting the system is
never going to work and even going to
higher orders won't work
but
you know you keep banging on this for a
while and
basically the idea is there's sort of
two steps now to solve this problem
um
the really three the first step is
try to figure out the range of these psd
matrices
so we have a set of matrices
try to find the range
this is non-trivial but if you start
playing around with projections of these
objects
uh what you start seeing is
projections of higher moments of this
gaussian basically look like
projections of these matrices but you
also get weird rank 1 components but it
turns out
you can do this to get the range of
these matrices
and then the point is is if you knew the
range of the matrices
you can then think about solving this
problem
in a different basis
and then we can argue it's invertible
okay so the game is kind of yet at a
high level the game is still we're going
to reduce it to a problem like this
where you make tensors out of the psd
matrices so each mu i is going to be a
matrix but we're going to do it through
some algebraic manipulations
so it turns out even in this very
general case
uh it works and the conditions we need
so now we just need to be in a
sufficiently high dimension to get
enough parameters and that's going to be
um
the number of gaussians need to be
bigger than the dimensions squared
and we think that can be relaxed
and then we can actually show in a
smooth analysis model this works where
uh it's really the strong version of
smooth analysis you you know with sort
of exponentially small probability
there's a failure probability and you
really will
solve this sort of mixture psd
matrix problem
so basically the high level point there
is
these techniques really seem to go the
distance
and that's an interesting
it's sort of an interesting observation
like were they somehow limiting but it
does feel like
uh for the non-degenerate cases if we're
in reasonably high dimension
uh these things are in fact generically
solvable and they're sort of generically
solvable
um
you know in a smooth analysis problem
so just wrap up there you know you can
look at the papers for
solving lda it's sort of a similar
similar set of tricks but again it's a
much easier set of tricks to get that to
work out
so in summary
basically looking at these problems as
inverse moment problems is a helpful way
to give us insight and
you know this
the algorithms seem promising because
basically these tensor methods you're
trying to find local minima of
sort of skewness and fourth moment
maximizer you're basically trying to
find spiky directions in your data and
as a heuristic this seems like a good
idea
but what's interesting is it also seems
to go the distance in some of these
harder problems uh with some tricks so
you know this has been joint work with a
number of very talented people uh daniel
was working with me on the stuff from
the beginning uh anna nema has you know
been a part of most of this work and she
gave a very nice talk under that work a
few days ago
most recently this
very difficult problem of learning a
mixture of zero mean gaussians which is
really
decomposing a tensor that's being made
up of psd matrices jumbled together
this was really
solved by some wonderful colleagues so
rong is a post-doc at msr new england uh
yeah he's really terrific and i had a
number of extremely talented interns
this last summer and uh ching ching was
one of them at mit
and uh yeah she was stunning i mean this
is her first four in ml and they really
made some wonderful progress on showing
how you can actually
recover this tensor made of
uh psd matrices so thanks
all right so this is a good question uh
because i'm saying you know these
systems are solvable and basically we
use the sixth moment
and
we need the number of gaussians k
to be bigger than d squared i'm going to
say
d squared is in the smooth analysis
model uh
we believe we can definitely do it
indeed of the 1.5 generically but we
just don't know how to show
uh meaning genetically that the set of
problems it fails on is measure zero but
if we want it to actually
uh you know perturb it and really work
with high probability we need d squared
uh but if you if you keep going to
higher and higher moments it's i believe
we can bring this down to d which
basically says
to forget about um
sample complexity a moment and just ask
the gen or the smooth analysis and just
ask
how many gaussians can we learn
in d dimensions using this technique and
with higher moments i think you can
bring it all the way down
to d
or constant times d
this is uh uh this isn't
uh sample complexity
issues this is
uh
getting a polytime algorithm and
we don't know how to we don't even know
how to prove identifiability for the
gener actually that's not true we don't
know how to solve the
equations when k is less than d because
somehow
um
like somehow
you
you're mixing up psd matrices and d
dimensions and we just don't know how to
um
it's like natural using this technique
because using general algebraic geometry
you know that there's always
well i mean that takes proof because you
have to show that these equations have
unique
okay right so
so that's right so so in certain cases
you can show uh uniqueness generically
solving them
like yeah there's just some
horrible side of algebraic equations and
we have no idea how to
solve well there are well there are
solvers but you you yeah they're solvers
but like you know even saying that these
are uh you know that it works in poly
time who knows
well not following the number of degrees
it's falling the rest of the things but
not boiling it's not pollen k and even
then
even then like it's murky what the
algebraic solvers uh get you right
okay
why become saltful if you have enough
mixture components
it seems to get harder with more
uh so think of it as uh it's not
oh sorry did i botch this uh
sorry sorry i i sorry i'm i'm
sorry i said no no this is totally wrong
right it's like this other way
yeah sorry this is a yes the worst case
is uh a mixture of gaussians on a line
that are all zero i mean uh
yes because uh
this is the right way and it's sort of a
parameter counting argument so
as long as you know we think we can drop
this down to k less than d
um
and
you know like how many parameters do you
have
for psd matrix is like you know n choose
2
and you're in n dimensions
but it's wacky because with this
technique going to higher moments we
don't know if
you get
you can
solve things any more easily and this is
just this funny thing about these way
these counting theorems work and i was
talking to santosh about this years ago
as we go to higher moments somehow
yeah we couldn't
the other case is there's a reason to
believe uh if you go to higher moments
you really can
get k to be bigger than
than d
and can you say some word more about the
fact that you choose orthogonal
assignments i don't understand because
most of tensor just do not have an
orthogonal decomposition so you assume
that
right
yes so the point here is as long as k is
less than d
okay so think of your think of just
randomly projecting your cancer down to
a matrix right then you get a sum of uh
mu i mu i
okay
you choose a metric
yeah but the point is you can al as long
as k is less than d
you can make these vectors you can work
in a basis to make them orthogonal
and
uh
and this i think is a deep question
because if k is bigger than d
can you actually
uh
uh no but it's even an identifiability
question how many can we unpack from
there and there's a really beautiful
result by
um
the algorithm is called like fubi fourth
order only blind deconvolution by i
think you don't spell his name dela
tower is one of the authors
and basically the argue with the four
tensor if it has d2's two objects in it
you can
recover them all exactly
and this trick clearly won't work but
you can yeah so you know this way yeah
it's it's a really topic has a nice uh
solver on uh as a toolbox of matlab and
uh works very well but only for small
rank of course but right but this one is
at least an algebraic method which
really shows identifiability generically
when
k is about d choose two and it shows
that the fourth moment can exactly
uh figure it out which is impressive
because you can't like you can't make
this orthogonal so this simple trick
doesn't work and it's a really it's a
beautiful paper it's like a page
line by line everything
makes sense just the intuition is monkey
but it's short
so you know
you kind of expect this at some level
because you get more parameters as you
go to higher moments but this is this is
me
okay
so questions